[Music]  hold up  it's load of fun voting when you're not  supposed to sir  [Music]  I'd vote if it ain't [ __ ] commit no  fraud  [Music]  [Music]  thank you  [Music]  they are disqualified from voting  because they've been convicted of either  murder or sexual assault  [Music]  thank you  foreign  and this happened years ago I don't know  when people get a voter ID card from  their government what else are they  going to present except that they're  eligible to vote  [Music]  Florida has very good election laws and  the states that don't have very good  election laws are the states that  actually have gone in the opposite  direction of weakening security for the  ballot Florida has an election law  police force  and if the laws are so wonderful  why what's the need for that